people are  more depressed more anxious more  suicidal and more addicted than they  were 30 years ago one of the main  reasons is because of this relentless  pursuit of pleasure we live in a world  in which we are saturated with dopamine  and we live in a culture which  encourages us to pursue it but the  ultimate end result of pursuing dopamine  is to feel worse than when you started  it's literally everything from the  billboards and the advertisements and  marketing messages crafted by madison  avenue to of course the devices that we  all carry around with us that are  specifically designed to  lure us into this you know dopamine  induced state yes exactly i mean  addiction can happen now in every realm  of life it's almost impossible to escape  it